you'll find something that you really
care about protect their own costs the
slow will be torn apart and how of the
ashes a dark hero will rise cities not
safe drop of blood in Gucci wine glass
makes me mad
the virus isn't disease the best thing
that's ever happened to me Mario has
Al's touches virus
the real virus jamming you seep into
people's lives until you destroy them
please
why'd you do this I want all your
darkness I am tired of sitting at the
kids table we can have it all I love Who
I am I'm gonna need anyone to tell me I
lost her I swore maybe you killed her
I can't betray Barbara she's always got
your best interests at heart
did you kill puss it's not like you gave
me a choice there's always a choice
my name is IRISA and then became him
when I killed you newsflash dead you
were the one time I've met of waking me
and I want you around as a constant
reminder to never make that mistake
again Gotham can be born again I am your
destiny
you've broken through your conditioning
don't control me anymore this is what
always best
[Applause]
what do you want I want more figured
this was a good place to start go along
I've been trying to find who I had for
so long Who am I supposed to be
now
you don't find something that you care
about
as you protect it costs how many find it
they'll never be nice together I can
make a difference in Gotham Alfred I
know I can
it's dangerous you are engaging villains
crane
encouraging here it's just a scarecrow
damn like christmas is coming full gcpd
no longer keep us safe I am not given
the city over to the pilot this is a war
not one battle ok not a chance don't say
I didn't warn you
I
what scares you the most there is time
for masks and there is Italian Turkish
way
you don't know anything about me Alfred
I feel more alive than I've ever felt
before
well Wow who are you huh rough night
Bruce dental fight Ronny
[Music]
you have a list I want it I'm done
playing nice the hell are you supposed
to
I'm all for you protecting the innocent
I wouldn't have you risking a knife is a
thin Kevlar weave with reinforced for
arm protection extremely lightweight and
actually bulletproof you know for rock
climbing never done for a closer look
how did I know you're gonna say that
you